we we had to really we talked about this
the last time you were on but Trump's
bite is is his bark is worse than his
bite right his policies were pretty good
at toward the end a year toward
beginning the year and then the shooting
happened and of course it was it was
like we talked about 64 the underwater
backwards backgammon where he was
actually pushing for some of this gun
control legislation now we don't really
know and here we have it this week with
the tariffs and the taxes this is
something I've always been against a lot
of people don't understand I think most
steep that the biggest partner in steel
I think we have in the United States or
aluminum as Canada yeah it's not China
it's Canada no 11 on the list
yeah China's number 11 on the list yeah
it did the the notion that we're being
screwed by Chinese steel is just not
true 70% of all steel consumed in the
United States is created in the United
States the steel industry produced five
percent more than they did last year the
year before so meaning that it's
actually growing the steel industry in
the United States the stock price at
companies like Nucor was like 10 bucks
at 2000 in 2000 now it's like 62 dollars
the United States been producing
approximately the same amount of steel
since 1983
it's just that only 25% the same number
of employees are required to produce
that amount of Steel because technology
is what's taking away the jobs not
competition from foreign sources so none
of this makes any sense for every job in
the steel industry there are at least 40
jobs that are dependent on products from
the steel industry meaning that if you
increase tariffs which increased prices
in the steel industry you're passing
those prices on to a bevy of other
industries and I'm sorry watching
billionaire Wilbur Ross on national
television holding up a Campbell's soup
can to explain to the poor why it is
that it doesn't matter that they're
paying a little bit more for their
canned soup is not real good press you
see I thought that was ten steel plate
at in write corrode right I don't know
exactly either way someone yeah it's
either way there's BPA and someone's
getting some cancer if it's Campbell's
soup from what I understand
just a little parrot I just need to buy
my oregano oil you'll feel good let me
ask you this there is there is some
inconsistency here because I understand
some people support this idea because
they feel like we've been screwed on
free trade now here there is some truth
to the kernel of truth right a good
example as I talked about this with
Ronald Reagan the least president the
least conservative thing he did was the
Harley Davidson fiasco the reason
Americans wanted Japanese bikes at the
time was because they were better and
one go back to the AMF days it's just
awful awful awful motorcycles and the
protectionism actually
hurt the consumer because we wanted to
preserve an American company that should
have gone bankrupt some people don't
care be American buy American so let's
put that aside because I know we're not
gonna get everyone to agree I think
everyone has to agree that there is a
while this is how I feel about this
there's a wildly inconsistent message
this week either the economy is
rip-roaring and it's booming and we're
doing fantastically and we can't take
enough winning or we're getting screwed
by foreign competitors and we need to
batten down the hatches
it seems like there are some mixed
signals I'm first roar and I think this
is one of the problems for Trump is that
he doesn't care about the numbers he's
not interested in the numbers and you
can see that cuz the stock market has
been down since these announcements
about the tariffs the markets are I've
been thrown into turmoil all the good
that was done by the tax cuts could
easily be taken away through a trade war
I think it's more about Trump has this
vision in his head of 19:56 America when
we were just making assembly line trucks
in and we were making our own steel in
Pittsburgh and in Gary Indiana and never
mind the fact that the sky was like
purple because of all that's being
tossed into the air in the production of
that he'll never find that mind the fact
that the Pittsburgh unemployment rate
today is 4.6 percent significantly lower
than it was during those days and the
air is breathable in Pittsburgh because
everybody is now in the healthcare
industry or the service industry right
it Trump has this and it's why I think
honestly there's such a gap in the
feelings about Trump between people who
are 60 and up and people who are 40
under people who are 40 and under look
at this and they go what are you even
talking about like you're talking about
the steel industry as though as the
steel industry goes so goes America I
don't know anybody who actually works in
the steel industry I know people in the
car industry I know people in the
service industry and then they're bunch
of people who are over 60 and they
remember working at a plant for 40 years
and getting their gold watch for a tire
man and they're thinking well finish
those days they would actually fix
everything